Traductor: Libni Falcón
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
(Música)
(Aplausos)
Les voy a preguntar esto.
¿Cuándo es más feliz un perro?
Les voy a dar opciones,
¿Cuando le estás por dar de comer?
¿o cuando ya le diste de comer?
Les voy a contar de mi perro, el Mandela,
ya escuché las respuestas,
se llama Mandela.
El Mandela cuando yo le estoy
por dar de comer
ya se da cuenta.
Me ve, ve los gestos que hago,
ve la llave que yo voy a buscar
que es la que abre el portón
donde está la comida
y ya identifica que sabe
que se viene su momento.
Y hasta yo puedo, si quiero,
estirar ese momento de felicidad de él,
tratando de hacerlo durar
hasta que llego al galpón.
Cuando pongo en el tacho,
y hace ruido, y él ve que se cargó,
alli ya está en el clímax de la felicidad.
Le doy de comer, allí me abandonó.
Ya no le importó más,
ya no me quiere más.
Se olvidó de mi, comió,
y se fue a dormir la siesta.
Segunda pregunta,
¿Cuándo es más feliz mi mujer,
que se llama Marcela,
cuando estábamos buscando
una casa para mudarnos?
¿O cuando encontramos la casa
y nos mudamos?
Era mucho más feliz
cuando estábamos buscando la casa.
¿Conocen ese momento?
Donde me mandaba un mail
mirá esta, y mirá esta
y en esta podemos hacer este cambio,
y en esta hacemos esta reforma,
y acá el baño, y acá la cocina.
No, sobre todo el baño, que no se porqué
siempre todo el baño
tiene que estar perfecto.
Como si fueramos a vivir en el baño.
Y ahí estaba entusiasmada.
Después, cuando vino el camión
de la mudanza ya,
cuando elegimos la casa donde
nos íbamos a mudar con nuestras hijas,
ahi el nivel de felicidad era distinto.
Y les voy a contar,
para seguir con esta reflexión,
lo que me pasó a mi cuando era chico.
Yo soy el mayor de cinco hermanos.
Y me acuerdo clarito que, en un momento,
con mi hermano Juan Andrés,
le pedimos a mi padre una bicicleta.
"Papá, queremos una bicicleta."
Mi viejo, tomando mate tranquilo
ni se estresó.
Ni consultó con mi madre,
ni consultó con nadie más.
Nos dijo tranquilamente:
¨Pídanla para Papá Noel¨.
Cero estrés.
Tengo cuarenta y siete años.
Me acabo de dar un análisis
de como pasó esto 40 años atrás.
No se estresaba mi viejo.
Y nosotros esperamos la bicicleta
todo el año sin medicación.
Todo el año, esperamos la bicicleta.
(Aplausos)
Y con mi hermano, Juan Andrés,
cuando llegó esa Navidad,
tenías que portarte bien.
Te tenía que ir bien en la escuela,
Tenía que acompañar,
como soy el mayor, a mis hermanos,
tenía que llevar a los más chicos.
Había algunas tareas que hacer
para después tener la bicicleta.
Cuando llegamos al montoncito en Navidad,
que mis viejos siempre regalaban así,
había un montoncito para
los hermanos mayores
y otro montoncito para los chicos.
Mis viejos regalaban así, chau.
Mi hermano se anima, Juan Andrés,
va, abre, y era un triciclo.
Y me mira, y yo le digo, "Gracias papá!"
Porque mi viejo me había enseñado
que teníamos que decir gracias.
¿Se acuerdan que antes
los padres enseñaban esto?
Tenías que decir gracias a lo que te tocó,
sea que era lo que habías pedido o no.
¿Me siguen?
Increíble, entonces
yo dije "Gracias, papá".
Y mi viejo: "Y tenés que
compartirlo con tu hermano".
(Risas)
Bueno, y ahí, a qué voy con esto,
que nosotros esperabamos todo el año,
esa espera tiene que ver con la felicidad.
Hoy en día confundimos
empacho con felicidad.
Y ¿qué es lo que pasa en
la sociedad actual?
Justamente nosotros venimos,
estamos metidos
en lo que hoy se llama:
la sociedad de la abundancia.
En la sociedad de la abundancia,
el lema es:
"No sé lo que quiero, pero lo quiero ya."
Y nuestros padres fueron educados
por sus papás, osea por nuestros abuelos
en la sociedad de la pobreza.
En la sociedad de la pobreza,
se crecía sabiendo que
no se podía lograr todo.
Se disfrutaba lo poco que se lograba.
¿Me siguen?
Se crecía sabiendo que
no se podía lograr todo.
Pero se disfrutaba lo poco que se lograba.
Se crecía en la esperanza.
Y la sociedad actual
es la sociedad de la abundancia.
¨No sé lo que quiero, pero lo quiero ya.¨
Cuánto drama tienen nuestros chicos hoy
que tienen mucho,
y ese mucho que tienen, es poco.
Porque este deseo y esta ansiedad,
cuando mis papás,
en el ejemplo que les puse antes,
esperaban todo el año, nos hacia desear,
nos hacia caminar.
En cambio hoy en dia,
si tapamos todos los deseos
de nuestros hijos,
no los dejamos desear, no los dejamos
tener ilusiones, tener expectativas,
y los hacemos confundir
empacho con felicidad,
que es la manera directa
donde se está entrando en los consultorios
por ansiedad y por depresión.
Entonces ¿qué es lo que pasa
con los padres de hoy?
Pasa que los padres de hoy
no educan como antes.
Y no digo esto en el tono
de que todo tiempo pasado fue mejor.
Por favor no, para mí no hay tiempo
más lindo que este que estamos vivos.
Pero los padres de hoy
estamos tan cansados,
tan estresados, con tanta culpa,
que no tenemos tiempo para decir que no.
No tenemos tiempo para educar.
¿Vieron que los padres de hoy
se sacan de encima a los chicos?
Llega el nené: "Papá, mamá"
"Andá con tu madre"
"Mamá, mamá"
"Andá con tu padre,
¿no ves que recién llego cansada?"
"Abuela", "Me estoy yendo" dice la abuela.
(Risas)
La abuela, ¡ja!
hay que cuidar a los abuelos ¿eh?
¡Oy! los abuelos, se están yendo...
es que la abuela educaba sin culpa.
En cambio nosotros
somos padres culpógenos,
que tenemos mucho miedo
que nuestros hijos no nos quieran,
y que no les dedicamos tiempo.
Educar es cansarse amorosamente.
No se puede educar descansado.
Tu hijo es un milagro, no es un problema.
Y tu tenés que tener tiempo
para decirle que sí,
y también para decirle que no.
Esto es parte de los padres de hoy:
el cansancio, el estrés, el agotamiento.
Y cómo nos damos cuenta
cómo repercute esto.
Bueno, esto repercute
en lo que quiero darles,
que es la formula de la felicidad.
¿Qué les parece?
(Aplausos)
Manos arriba.
La fórmula de la felicidad,
La fórmula de la felicidad es
que nuestros hijos
nos vean felices a nosotros,
y que tengamos nosotros
el coraje de ser adultos,
y ayudar a que nuestros hijos
hospeden sus frustraciones.
El mejor tutorial de felicidad...
El mejor tutorial de felicidad
para nuestros hijos es tu cara.
Es la cara con que nosotros llegamos
y les decimos a nuestros hijos:
"No sabés lo lindo
que me fue en mi trabajo,
o de buscar trabajo¨.
Y si preciso mentir, miento.
Porque no tenemos derecho
a contagiarles nuestros rayes
a nuestros hijos.
Porque aunque les parezca mentira,
nuestros hijos quieren ser como nosotros.
(Aplausos)
Y ¿qué es lo que está pasando?
Que nosotros estamos pecando
de sobreproteger.
Y me incluyo.
Tengo dos hijas,
Martina 18, y Belén de 15.
Nosotros hemos sobreprotegido
a nuestros padres
más de lo que nuestros padres
nos sobreprotegieron a nosotros.
Es una generalidad.
Y ¿eso qué quiere decir?
Proteger es fantástico.
Proteger es cuidar
las emociones de nuestros hijos,
las necesidades físicas,
afectivas, espirituales,
que tienen nuestros hijos.
Pero sobreproteger es cuando
hago algo que el niño o el adolescente
puede hacer por sí mismo.
Cuando le resuelvo algo,
porque estoy cansado, apurado,
Y no vieron que son los papás de hoy,
que le atan los cordones
hasta los cinco años al niño.
Le ponen la campera,
¿me explico?
Los bañan, los llevan y los traen.
¿Conocen?
Este es el cansancio del padre
que sobreprotege.
Sobreproteger es cuando hago algo
que el niño puede hacer por sí mismo.
Y de esa manera anulo su autoestima.
Anulo su independencia.
Anulo su iniciativa y anulo
la confianza en sí mismo.
El gran drama que tenemos hoy en día
es que los padres no se bancan
que sus hijos sufran.
Y si no sufren, no crecen.
Porque donde hay vida, hay sufrimiento.
Pero no en el sentido de que
"ojalá que sufra", no.
De que le quiere pegar a la hermana
y tú le decís:
"no se le pega a la hermana".
¨Pero, vos no estabas, mirá, ¿no
le puede pegar un poquito?¨ ¨No¨.
(Risas)
Y esa es la tarea del adulto.
El gran drama que tenemos hoy
es que no hay adultos
que se banquen la frustracion
de que tengo que decirle a mi hija:
"No se le pega a la hermana".
Es normal que le quiera pegar.
Tengo que ayudarlo de que a los cinco años
tenga la capacidad de
autoregular sus emociones.
Y a los padres que sobreprotegen,
les duele el posible dolor del nene
antes de que le duela.
¿Oyeron eso?
Se está por caer, ya le duele.
Y como me duele antes de que le duela,
y yo no quiero que él sufra
lo que yo sufrí,
hago cosas para que no le duela.
Como hago cosas para que no le duela,
no le duele
y como no duele, no crece.
Y si lo exilio del sufrimiento,
lo exilio del aprendizaje
que ese sufrimiento trae.
Mucho coraje precisamos hoy
para ser adultos.
(Aplausos)
¿Qué hacer entonces?
Por eso decimos que sobreproteger
es como la nueva forma de maltrato.
Porque estamos entregando
chicos a la sociedad
que se los comen en dos panes.
¿Me explico?
Porque tienen un psiquismo frágil,
que cuando en el trabajo les dicen:
"Para el viernes
tenés que entregar este informe.",
el chico dice ¨Renuncio¨.
(Risas)
¨No me gustó como me habló ¿sabés?¨
¨Vos nunca me hablaste así papá.¨
Entonces, ¿dónde van a sacar
la felicidad nuestros chicos?
Si nosotros los exiliamos del aprendizaje
que trae el sufrimiento
que es que se va a caer,
pero gracias a que se cae,
aprenderá a andar en bicicleta,
aprenderá a usar una computadora,
aprenderá a manejarse en el mundo.
Por eso esto, ¿qué hacer entonces?
Nosotros precisamos adultos
y para ser adultos
precisamos dejar de ser
hijos de nuestros padres.
Yo soy hijo si reclamo,
yo soy hijo si no perdono.
Yo soy hijo si todavía creo
que mi infancia puede ser
distinta de la que fue.
Ser adulto es tener el coraje
y la humildad de agradecer
a nuestros viejos que hicieron
lo que pudieron
con las herramientas que tuvieron.
Y nosotros llegar a casa,
y poderle decir a tu hijo
un beso y un abrazo.
Pero si tiene un capricho,
o si le va a pegar a la hermana,
poder decirle con total tranquilidad
y con total alegría
"Te dije que no y es no, hijo".
Sin miedo y sin culpa.
No te va a agradecer ahora,
lo que estamos haciendo por ellos.
Fíjense a nosotros cuanto tiempo
nos llevó agradecerle a nuestros viejos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Música)